una escena demasiado familiar en eeuu se
encienden las protestas porque otro
hombre afroamericano terminó muerto a
manos de la policía
down right fue abatido durante un retén
de tránsito en el norte de mineápolis a
16 kilómetros de donde george floyd fue
asesinado dijo que la policía lo hizo
parar
le pregunté por qué me dijo que lo
hicieron desviarse hacia la cuneta
porque llevaba ambientadores colgando
del retrovisor solo tenía 20 años no
merecía que le dispararan y lo matarán
así el departamento de policía de
brooklyn center dice que durante el
retén de tránsito descubrió que wright
tenía una orden de captura pendiente y
que lo intentaron arrestar él volvió al
auto y uno de los agentes disparó su
arma y el conductor acabó estrellándose
la policía asegura que sus cámaras
corporales y las del coche patrulla
estaban activadas aunque se ha iniciado
una investigación sobre el tiroteo para
quienes protestan esta muerte prueba la
urgencia de una reforma policial
solo estamos protestando no
continuaremos aceptando que la policía
maté a gente negra sin razón paradas de
tránsito ya sabes problemas mentales
esta es sólo una manera que hemos
aprendido para solidarizarnos y
demostrar que estamos defendiendo una
causa
el ambiente en mineápolis ya está tenso
por el juicio al ex policía de erección
acusado del asesinato de george floyd
joven presionó su rodilla sobre el
cuello de floyd durante nueve minutos el
proceso entra en su tercera semana